hey guys Pete here today I'm gonna do a
better call Saul season 5 episode 7
preview AMC has released the short
trailer which I'll breakdown
scene-by-scene
and there's also a sneak peak clip
before we get into that this will be
your spoiler warning in these videos I
talk about everything that's happened in
better call Saul and Breaking Bad up
into this point I also look at all the
extra stuff that's out there in the
media if you don't like that kind of
stuff this video won't be for you so
make sure you subscribe before you lead
though because I do cover better call
Saul and do recaps each week and I'll be
doing that all the way through to the
end of the series at the end of season 6
episode 7 of season 5 is titled JMM it
seems like that would be a reference to
the bag that Kim gave to Jimmy that had
his initials on it it was written by
Allison Tatlock who wrote number 502 50%
off earlier this season and something
stupid back in season 4 which was the
episode where we had a big time jump as
Jimmy was working his way through PPD
it's directed by Melissa Bernstein which
I thought might be a mistake when I saw
that on the internet because she's long
been a producer slash executive producer
for Breaking Bad and better call Saul
but she's never been a director if you
ever watched the BTS videos or listened
to the insider podcast you'll know who
she is and that she plays a crucial role
in the Breaking Bad universe so it's
pretty interesting that she's gonna have
her first go in the director's chair the
episode description reads Jimmy and Kim
build a legal firewall with the help of
Huell kim sets things straight with her
clients as Jimmy is compromised by his
Gus calms troubled waters and service of
his plot to build an empire Mike does
damage control this is a pretty exciting
trailer too if not for any other reason
that all the major characters show up in
it everybody's in this we've finally got
to the point where both sides of the
story are in a collision course for each
other
Jimmy and Kim are still together Jimmy
works for Lalo who was locked up by a
plan that Mike set in motion Gus and
Mike are getting their information about
the Salamanca's from nacho who is forced
to play both sides and it looks like
they're gonna use that information to
put pressure on Jimmy in order to make
him do what they want when it comes to
representing Lalo finally all the
character
are involved in the primary story which
all revolves around Jimmy the trailer
opens with nacho waiting for Mike we see
them have a conversation and one of
those out-of-the-way locations that they
like to use Mike says to him what are
you holding out I don't really know what
he's talking about here we presume that
this is the conversation that Mike
agreed to in the last episode when he
was talking to nacho that should be in
relation to nacho wanting to get his
father who's an innocent out of harm's
way but this what are you holding out
that might have something to do with
Lalo or the Salamanca family that he's
not letting on you know mike has a sense
that there's more to the story we see
Lalo in his bunk in a jail cell since he
had a handgun under the front seat of
his car you know that seemed pretty
obvious that he would end up there like
I said in my last video though I really
doubt this will be the end of his story
and we'll talk a little bit more about
that as we go after that we see Kim and
rich talking to Kevin in his office Kim
says we owe you the truth later in the
trailer we see a little bit more of this
there's a shot of Kevin's face reflected
in a photo of him and his dad and that's
followed with a shot of Kim and rich
outside the office the sneak peak scene
that AMC released shows Kim apologizing
to Kevin with rich and doing damage
control to try to keep the arrangement
in place she says when Mesa Verde asked
her to be their lawyer that was the best
day of her professional life she says
that yesterday referring to Jimmy stunt
was the worst day of her professional
life I imagine they're gonna take her
back but but there may be more going on
behind the scenes because there may be
some fallout between her and Rich based
on what we see obviously he suspected
she was in cahoots with Jimmy they
pulled it off in the way that she didn't
actually know what he was going to do
but that still may be a problem as far
as rich is concerned and honestly I
don't know where else they're going with
that so I feel like something has to
happen as that shakes out we see Jimmy
at home in his kitchen making orange
juice and we hear Mike on the phone say
I need a word so the implication here is
that Mike's reaching out on behalf of
Gus because he found out that Jimmy is
Lalo's lawyer we see Howard he runs into
Jimmy face-to-face at the courthouse and
says so have you thought any more about
the job there's not much indication of
what's going on here but I expect that
we'll have some kind of exchange where
he makes his intentions known why he
wants Jimmy at this time what Rollie
season playing I say that because I
think this reminds me of the trailer
that was out preseason where Jimmy says
you don't know what I'm capable of
either way we know Jimmy's not gonna
probably take a job at HHM but but there
should be some sort of conclusion to
this whole situation in the near future
then we see Huell sitting in the public
records office now marriage licenses are
public records we see a pamphlet behind
him that says what to do if you lose
your birth certificate the theory I saw
people putting out there was that this
line Jimmy and Kim built a legal
firewall with the help from Huell is
about heal being the witness at their
wedding basically that they'll get
married right away
that is a big question that's on
everyone's mind obviously I'm not really
sure what else he could be up to it says
public records right on the door it
looks like it might say something about
marriage license on the sign in the
hallway so I feel pretty certain that
this has something to do with them
getting married
I'm liking his jacket here his lapels
are bedazzled which is a nice touch
after that we see Jimmy outside a
building on the phone probably the same
building where he will is or the
courthouse which is all maybe the same
building for what it's worth he's
probably talking to nacho he says who
got picked up this time Jimmy's asking
about what they need him for because he
took care of the krazy-8 situation for
them earlier in the season and he's
about to find out that Lalo got locked
up there's a shot of Gus somewhere
public with a desk sign for los Pollos
hermanos with his name and title on it
it's hard to say where this is later we
see him closing a door and what looks
like a hotel room we see the Do Not
Disturb sign hanging on the door handle
with the image of a steer I don't know
if any of that is a big clue to where he
is but it said he'd be calming troubled
waters and service of his plot to build
an empire which could be about Los
Pollos or it could be about his drug
business after that we get a shot of Kim
and Jimmy having a conversation at a
table outside somewhere
as to him I just want to know what's
going on this is interesting because it
seems like she's saying that she wants
to know what Jimmy does as Saul if you
think about the progression of things as
he's been doing stuff as Saul he's been
keeping her in the dark she didn't know
about the burner phones until she knew
about him he never explained what
happened on that day when he met Lalo
and so on if they're married she can't
be compelled to testify against him so
she may be laying ground rules here and
the interest of not being surprised
about what he's into just like saying
look I understand you're gonna be this
guy Saul and you're gonna do what you're
gonna do but I need to know what's going
on because we're in a relationship this
opens the door to her finding out about
his involvement with the cartel though
and that could have repercussions in a
couple of ways she could try to stop him
and the reality is even if we didn't
know who he was in Breaking Bad we know
that once you're in you're in
now that the cartel is using him he's
not gonna get away from it her knowing
also means that she herself could be a
loose end for them but that's just a
guess of what's going on here so we'll
just have to wait and see we have Mike
visiting Jimmy at home he's at his place
giving him documents in preparation for
whatever they have planned he says this
is everything you need to do your job
which to me means that Gus has direction
for how he wants Jimmy to proceed in
representing Lalo there's a shot of
Jimmy in the courthouse sort of peeking
around the corner that makes for a funny
looking shot and then we see Jimmy and
Kim in front of what looks like a
courtroom it looks like they're waiting
for a judge to enter the room but it's
not exactly clear what's going on could
be related to them getting married but
it's also followed with a shot of Lalo
being brought into a courtroom in
shackles he's still wearing his jumpsuit
so we can guess he was transported
straight from the jail to make this
appearance could be a bail hearing or an
arraignment hearing where the judge
formally states his charges he enters
his plea can't tell but we do hear the
bailiffs say all rise and then the
trailer ends with a long shot of Mike
and nachos meeting with their cars in
the background so a lot of interesting
stuff here mostly around the fact that
everyone's getting together the big
question on everyone's minds is why did
Kim propose that they get married will
that actually happen
I'm not gonna speculate too much about
why she did what she did because I
already talked about that some in the
previous video but also because I don't
think we really know yet it was set up
as a cliffhanger the short answer is she
should leave Jimmy because being with
him is not good for her but she's in
love with him so that's not going to
happen
people are really jumping forward with
this idea that the marriage is to
insulate her from having to testify
against Jimmy if something goes wrong
and he gets in trouble that would be a
legal firewall so there's probably
something to that I just think that if
you talk about that too much you sort of
missed the point that Kim also did this
because she wants to stay together with
Jimmy unless she's scamming him she's
actually doubling down on the
relationship and staying together one of
the things to keep in mind is that what
Jimmy did to her if it didn't involve
her I mean it was a perfect example of
part of the reason that she's attracted
to him in the first place so I'll just
leave that there for now because this
video is going to turn out to be really
long and it's just a preview so we'll
have more to talk about in the recap of
the next episode the other really
interesting thing will be to see how
Jimmy gets caught up in this situation
what is Lala gonna do he's going to be
locked up he's gonna have a plan to get
out Gus is going to be trying to
undermine that I'm not really sure but
the thing I feel sure about is that
there's more to Lalo's story I don't
think that seeing him get arrested in
the last episode was the end of his
making trouble for Gus in the cartel
we'll have a lot better of an idea of
what he's trying to do and how Gus is
trying to stop him but in the timeline
four years from now when Walt and Jesse
take sole out at gunpoint into the
desert Saul is afraid that Lalo is the
person that put them up to it he tries
to sell out nacho in that conversation
so I don't think what's happening now is
what he's talking about then I think
there's still more to tell but let me
know what you guys think in the comments
how excited are you that both the
lawyers story and the cartel story is
all together as one we're in the final
stretch of this season so how do you
want to see things end up
well Kim and Jimmy get married and just
in general what do you want to see
happen please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already thanks
for watching I will
talk to you soon
[Music]
you